Disney's Moana took the world by storm
in 2016 we loved how Moana followed her
heart and embarked on an unforgettable
oceanic journey with Maui's help Moana
retrieved taffy Dee's stolen heart and
brought peace and order back to the
world she lives in it's hard to believe
that the movie could have ended in a
very different way watch until the end
to find out which alternate ending
almost got the greenlight mallanna's
brothers when you think about it it's
very uncommon for Disney Princesses to
have any siblings of their own sure they
might be surrounded by woodland
creatures or house pests but this
doesn't exactly qualify as family with
this in mind we were surprised to find
out that Disney originally had a very
different storyline in place for the
Polynesian princess believe it or not
but one of Disney's first Moana drafts
included Seven Brothers
yes that's right mallanna wouldn't have
been the Chiefs only child so by default
she probably wouldn't have been chosen
to lead her people at the end of the
movie either in this version of the
story chief chewy wasn't afraid of the
ocean and allowed his seven sons to sail
the stormy seas
sadly the ocean was no place for a young
girl so chief tui forbade Moana from
sealing alongside her brothers even
though she was a better sailor than all
of them combined although this storyline
could have been interesting it would
have taken away a lot of Moana screen
time on top of that it would make chief
tui come off as a sexist which isn't
exactly ideal for this day and age in
the end Disney Jose to forego storylines
that were based on gender rights and
equality and chose to side with an
independent woman's journey instead
bonding time when Maui first meets Moana
he sees her as his ticket off the island
and not as his salvation so he soon
traps her under a huge boulder and
leaves her for the birds it takes a long
time for these two characters to warm up
to each other in fact we only see a
connection form between the two of them
during the second half of the film
well apparently Disney wants one of
these two characters to bond much
earlier than they did in fact Moana and
now we were supposed to become friendly
shortly after sailing off together the
two would have bonded during the song
warrior face in which Maui taught Moana
how to defend herself and seal her bow
at the same time however this musical
number was eventually cut from the
storyline during
interview with cinema blend co-director
John Musker revealed why warrior face
didn't make the final cut according to
him this song felt like it sort of
duplicated some of the other songs and
they wanted a different bonding moment
and the bonding almost came too early
the director added that the song had to
be deleted to prevent Moana and the
demigod from bonding before the
underworld scene could take place all in
all we can't help but agree with Musker
because well Maui's disdain for Moana
and vice-versa was downright hilarious a
very sassy hey hey creating a character
from scratch isn't an easy thing to do
which is why animators tend to draw
inspiration from nature hey hey the
rooster was quickly adopted into the
storyline however his character
development just wasn't resonating with
mallanna's lightheartedness ka was
originally supposed to be a sassy bird
with a very different face in fact the
movies writer Jared Busch revealed that
hey hey started out as a jerk with too
much attitude this pesky rooster was
even made to steal food from puah making
him off as a total bully bush revealed
that he was having a hard time
connecting with the rooster so it was
soon agreed upon to change hey Hays
behavior altogether to make him more
likable Bush gave him a lower IQ and a
string of dopey facial expressions
despite changing the characters core
foundations Bush chose to keep his
original sassy name animators were able
to make the rooster more lovable by
placing him into ridiculous scenarios
it's hard to imagine what Mona's voyage
would have been like without the
dim-witted pet so we're super happy that
Bush chose to put a different spin on
hey haze personality although it's hard
to believe some characters were created
and cut out of the film altogether keep
watching to find out which Moana
personality didn't make it to the finish
line
hooah almost joined Mona's journey
mulana fans were devastated when they
saw the princess Lapua on the shoreline
and sail away many people felt as though
Moana should have brought her porky
friend on board after all who was super
adorable and we would have liked for him
to receive more screen time funny enough
in the earlier drafts
he joined Moana on her quest however it
was later determined that he would stay
behind so why did Disney ditch the pig
and opt for the rooster well because
Moana was supposed to feel out of her
element and
puah helped her feel at home hey hey on
the other hand caused more problems than
he helped solve making him the ideal
companion during an interview with E W
Musker revealed that he still had mixed
feelings about leaving puah behind the
co-director further explained the reason
why he was left out on Mata Nui and this
is what he had to say the pig was
supposed to go with her but we sort of
got talked out of it
they liked mallanna being more isolated
stuck with this idiot rooster and not
having the comfort of having the pig
with her there were cute scenes that we
don't have so there you have it guys the
movie would be completely different if
the pig had been allowed to join on
Mona's epic journey doesn't give you
power to create life it's a homing
beacon of death my team Aoi directors
John Musker and Ron Clements worked
together to create the storyline for the
beloved Disney movie Moana oddly enough
their original draft was nothing like
the movie we know and love when John and
Ron first pitched their idea to
executive producer John Lasseter he was
intrigued but not completely sold
originally John and Ron wanted to create
a movie called mighty Maui and Maui was
set to play the lead character as a
matter of fact Moana wasn't even a
concept yet the directors were intrigued
by ancient Maui myths and wanted to mash
up some of the dummy gods best stories
into one great film
however Lasseter chose to send the
directors to a string of Pacific Islands
so they could get a real grasp of the
culture it didn't take long for John and
Ron to fall in love with the islands and
the way of the people they soon realized
that navigation played a huge role in
this part of the world's history on top
of that they quickly picked up on how
the locals saw the ocean as a living and
breathing bean so by the end of their
trip the directors had a very different
storyline in mind and this is how chief
mallanna's story came to life baby Moana
when Moana was just a baby the ocean
came to pay her a visit
the opening scene showed viewers just
how connected Moana was to the ocean
despite not being allowed to venture
into its depths from the looks of it
Moana was chosen by the ocean a long
time ago heck it even brought her to
defeat his heart for safekeeping
although the sea has a scary reputation
this scene showed us just how gentle and
caring it could be the movies directors
wanted to give the ocean a bold analogy
and this on-screen moment seemed to do
it justice
so it's hard to believe that Disney
almost scrapped this segment while in
search of something better
animators fell in love with Mona's first
encounter with the sea so they were
totally bummed out in the gorgeously
animated sequence was put on the back
burner luckily for us the storyline
later shifted which allowed for it to
slip back in if this scene hadn't made
the cut
fans would have seen Moana become chummy
with the ocean during the first
expedition however we think that their
initial encounter is beyond perfect if
you start singing I'm gonna throw up
bawled Maui Ron Clements and John Musker
knew early on that they wanted to Wayne
Johnson to voice the character Maui so
they felt compelled to model Maui after
his voice actor choosing to make Maui
bald was a very practical decision since
a lot of hard work and money goes into
animated long and bouncy hair however
when the directors pitched their idea to
their advisors they were hit with a
reality check according to the advisers
maui isn't bald he has this long rich
hair that's part of his spiritual energy
so John and Ron told animators to give
Maui a mane of silky hair and they
totally flipped out you see there are
two things animators have trouble
perfecting water and hair and since
Moana is no stranger to oceanic
landscapes and healthy and bouncy hair
animators had their work cut out for
them although mastering Moana and Maui's
Locks was a challenge it helped make the
movie look ultra realistic in fact it's
hard to picture Maui without a single
hair on his head
after all we're so used to his effort
list top knot and luscious curls the a
tide fad you may or may not have noticed
that the Moana movie has a few eight
eyed bats in it this strange animal once
had a huge role in this film
however the 8id bat was eventually cut
from the movies production still it
managed to make a few small appearances
which makes sense considering the
character had already been designed we
clearly see Maui roll the bat into a
ball and send it flying during his song
you're welcome and the battery appears
for a split second when Maui and Moana
first venture into the monster realm so
what's the big deal about this bat and
why does he keep popping up throughout
the film
well the a tied bat was supposed to be a
gigantic monster who tried to stop our
heroes from entering la loti
in fact an entire scene was created with
the bat as the main antagonist in the
scene Maui and Moana were shown blowing
into coconuts to distract the bat with
hopes of getting past him the a died fat
was part of their earliest drafts so
when things began to change his scene
was deleted
grandma Tala almost didn't make the cut
although it may be hard to believe
grandma Tala was one of the last
characters to be added to the Moana
storyline it took writers a few rewrites
before they realized that a wise and
fearless personality could help this
story unfold after all it was grandma
Tala who helped Moana reconnect with her
ancestral roots on top of that grandma
Tala also encouraged Moana to return to
feed his heart to its rightful owner
despite chief TUI's strict orders
without grandma Tala
Milana story would definitely be a mess
without her grandmother's divine
intervention the Polynesian princess
would never have had the courage to keep
on going during their trip to the
Pacific Islands director John and Ron
met a woman named nanano Murphy this
woman was used as inspiration for
Grandma Tallis character so basically if
there's a real-life Grimm out there and
she's super spectacular is something you
want to hear the alternate ending Moana
teaches us a very important lesson at
the end of the film it teaches us that
people can heal and restore their true
beauty even after losing a part of their
heart when Maui stole to feed his heart
he turned her in to take ah a villainous
monster whose grief would eventually
swallow the world finding the perfect
ending for this film proved to be a real
challenge which is why many endings were
created and rejected in fact Moana was
originally going to end with Maui
returning to feed his heart however
producers felt that this made Maui the
star of the third act and they wanted
their girl Moana to be the hero for the
longest time Moana was convinced that
her mission was to bring Maui to tepee
tea but during the final battle she
realized that her mission had been to
return the heart herself all along a
handful of alternate endings nearly made
it to the finish line but in the end
directors fell in love with the one
that's currently being used in earlier
versions motu nui was made to sink to
the bottom of the ocean only to be
pulled back up by Maui's hook
luckily the island was able to remain in
peace during Mona's absence before you
go let us know
which behind-the-scenes secret was your
favorite in the comments below give this
video a big thumbs up if you think hua
is the cutest for more videos like this
one make sure to subscribe to the things
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]